from calorie counts to portion sizes we
wanted to find all the differences
between dominoes in China and in the US
this is food Wars
[Music]
here in China Domino's comes in three
sizes the seven inch small which is only
available for two pizzas the fruit
Deluxe and the cocoa brownie hand tossed
only the nine inch regular and the 12
inch large in the US our Domino's Pizzas
come in four sizes small 10 inch medium
12 inch large 14 inch and the XL 16
inches no there's nothing on your screen
the pizza is in fact that greasy
we have three types of crust
pan crust hand tossed and the thin crust
and eight different crust options
including stuffed crusts which are only
available outside of the US the UK has
them we have a sweet potato
stuffed crust you see that the orangey
bit in there
I was pretty good actually it reminds me
a little bit of a moon cake in that it's
sweet and savory
stuffed sausage crust just a little
sausage peeking out the hole but lettuce
crust and basically it's a mushroom it's
a variety of mushroom of which there are
many different species they're actually
poisonous so you need to cook them
properly if they're undercooked they
will cause hallucinations uh the
mushroom seller I met her husband
actually was poisoned four times and
once he saw a bunch of skulls either
side of him once he saw a mountain of
gold one other time he just beats up a
fridge and the last time he slept for
three days
and just taste like wet mushroom
actually we do have mushrooms that make
it hallucinate in the US as well
although you can't get them at Domino's
salted egg yolk stuffed crust it's
recommended that this is paired with the
chicken pizza so you basically have the
whole family in there
not as delicious it tastes like a
million calories such a guilty pleasure
the meat floss stuffed crust it's not
the most appetizing name is it it looks
a little bit like lint but it tastes
like bacon cotton candy usually it's
made of pork but you can also get it as
beef or chicken or fish I don't think it
quite Works in crust when crust is
already so dry we also have something
called the double decker thin and the
double decker sick correct me if I'm
wrong I think this is actually the
double decadence from the UK
I mean it is pretty much a pizza
sandwich U.S dominoes we have five
different dough varieties a better way
of saying that is five different crust
options dough varieties yeah same thing
anyway first one down here is a
gluten-free crust and I want to note it
only comes in the small because from
Domino's perspective if you want
gluten-free pizza you're eating it by
yourself next is the hand toss the kind
of the classic style right everyone's
seen the hand tossed to me it's the
default setting after that this is the
crunchy thin cutting the squares and
there's a Tavern cuts for all you in the
midwest another crust dough variety is
the pan this is a thick boy only comes
in a medium and of course the last one
is the Brooklyn style which you only get
in the large or the extra large and it's
thin and also has these really big
slices I can't tell that's eight slices
right no six slices right so it should
be eight I don't know can someone in
post increase the contrast on that to
maybe make the lines a little more
obvious
odometer's largest pizza has a diameter
of 12 inches or 30.5 centimeters and an
area of
730.6 centimeters squared and costs 88
Yuan or
12.81 USD breaking that down our pizza
is 0.11 Yen per square centimeter take
our large 14 inch or
35.56 centimeter pizza with an area of
993.1 square centimeters that's
0.015 cents per square centimeter or
.096 Yuan that means our U.S Domino's
Pizza per square inch is roughly 12.5
percent cheaper than in China
our Domino's categorizes their pizzas
into three groups Indulgence classic and
value let's take a look at the indulgent
first French style livermousse ham Pizza
I'm not even sure what a liver moose is
I assume it's meant to be fraguar it
smells like fragra
boom
but it is weird with pizza man no that
should not be eaten with pizza that is
super weird why hmm no let's grab some
New Zealand lamb
it may be New Zealand land but they've
used a lot of cumin and basically turned
it into a lamb skewer definitely miles
better after that the sultan durian
pizza that is a really healthy big piece
of durian Avalon and scallop indulgent
Pizza I mean just why Avalon is super
expensive and it's popular in China
because its name sounds like to get
explosively rich so you'll often find it
served at weddings at Chinese New Year
oh let's clean our palette we'll get
some Australian New Zealand wagyu beef
I'd eat the beef by itself I'd remove
everything else crayfish and chicken I
think they've gone full Nola here
because the chicken are meant to be all
lean chicken and then we got damn crawl
that is too chicken and crawdads I love
New Orleans food so yeah I would
definitely try that Pizza South American
ribeye steak the Burdock prawn bacon
indulgent Pizza we've got peas we've got
prawns we've got some cherry tomatoes
this is the Japanese style eel pizza and
on the description it actually says may
contain soft bones eat with a care
well they're very tasty though here we
have the Australian slash South American
grain-fed dice beef so they either
weren't sure where the beef was sourced
from or if they run out of beef from
Australia they go to South America and
over here we have a pineapple shrimp
Pizza you know for those of you who hate
Hawaiian pizzas this must be so much
more triggering nah I think it's
actually worse than a Hawaiian also in
the indulgent lineup is a regular durian
Pizza this is actually a best seller it
costs nine Yen less than the sultan oh
yeah no that's great
oh that's delicious here we have the
okonomiyaki surf and turf look at that
that's actually pretty decent it's even
got the hurikake in tag look at that
these little super thin flakes
mmm that's decent well done no that's
pretty good
very meaty too bacon meat floss potato
pizza
and it is absolutely blanketed in meat
floss and a gigantic potato wedge it's a
little bit like the Hawaiian pizza
except instead of a juicy pineapple you
have sweet
bacon flavored cotton candy not sure if
like the Domino's us menu obviously is
not as robust as China's Domino's menu
but there are some specialty pizzas you
can get here you can't get there
including these first one here is the
extravagan two capital z's ah this looks
like a rebranding of what would be
called a supreme pizza here right now if
you hate vegetables don't worry you can
get the same pizza but just meet the
version we got sausage ham pepperoni
possibly hamburger
this could have been just a sausage and
pepperoni pizza and it probably would
have tasted the same I'm just saying
Philly Cheesesteak Philadelphia let us
know in the comments how insulted you
are that the sandwich that fares your
name is now in Pizza form and this thing
looks terrifying steak cheese like that
onion and uh green pepper oh and
mushrooms
not bad I don't want a whole thing of
this though I already just one bite I'm
like me I got it it's more than novelty
of yeah I guess it does taste like a
Philly cheese steak but also I gotta get
this little pizza
the Cali chicken bacon ranch which I'm
gonna go ahead and assume is what do you
think chicken bacon some sort of ranch I
don't know what makes it California
not bad buffalo chicken in China they
had all these really interesting flavor
combinations I'm sure someone was just
you know really trying to capture the
breadth of Chinese tastes here
everything is like this exists somewhere
else sweetest in a pizza form case in
point buffalo chicken Haiti like wings
yeah do you want it in Pizza form no too
bad buffalo chicken uh another one here
spinach and feta
no because I've been bitten for some
side of Truth No another specialty pizza
we have exclusive to us and not in China
is a Wisconsin six cheese which assuming
from the name has
go ahead and guess six cheeses and I
said Wisconsin on there because
Wisconsin is the cheese steak shout out
to Wisconsin on to our classic offerings
beginning with the Salted egg yolk
flavored chicken which as you can see
was very welcomed by the crew we were
already missing two pieces the Chinese
name for this is Golden Sands which is a
specific way of cooking The Salted egg
yolk so that it becomes a sort of frothy
paste that can be used to coat various
things it's a salty sweet
umaminess teriyaki beef potato pizza
teriyaki beef yes the pizza itself is
already quite starchy it's all carbs and
then a potato on top of that it's a
staple on a staple
most of these pizzas are sweet pea King
Duck Pizza
I'm very conflicted about this I like
that they're representing us but this
looks very Blasphemous to me that
actually sounds amazing
nope nope nope nope Blasphemous no okay
never mind I'd still try it though here
we've got the tuna Seafood Deluxe not
that big a fan of seafood Pizza myself
truffle flavored sauce mushroom and
chicken pizza two types of mushrooms in
that pizza but note that the Truffle is
a flavored sauce so that's not included
as one of the types of mushrooms
normal Pizza yes chorizo Pizza I don't
know why there's Peas on all of the
pizza but look I'm gonna take it for
just regular meat toppings yes chorizo
get in here
tastes like bolognese sauce but it's
okay I can do that especially after all
this stuff I'll take anything and now
our value options beginning with the
Texas barbecue now the description says
it has Texas style meat I assume it's
ham again it's sweet but here it says
it's a barbecue sauce maybe a honey
glaze I'm okay with that the lychee
chicken pizza don't know why it's paired
up like that this is actually a pretty
nemarific Pizza the name is very punny
and it references a middle-aged Chinese
influencer who screams at the top of his
lungs
which kind of just translates to come on
many times people have said that I kind
of look like that guy and it's just I
don't know what it's talking about
there's no resemblance whatsoever
all I taste is a lychee the potato bacon
pizza this is one of Domino's all-time
best sellers and the name in Chinese
actually says American style I don't
know this is what you guys eat over in
Yonder
nope here we go here's a taste of
America
land of the free
who am I to judge I don't know what kind
of potato wedges Americans like to put
on their Pizza Korean style fried
chicken
also with sesame seeds seaweed marinara
sauce and it looks like onions
hey that's a winner
winner winner chicken dinner
veggie Deluxe not touching it over here
we have something special these are our
two smallest pizzas the seven inches
this is the fruit Deluxe Peach blueberry
jam pineapple coconut gel
um
you know what's best it's actually meant
to be sweet if I've tried one dessert
pizza I'm gonna try the other one the
cocoa flavored brownie pizza with
brownie cubes and cocoa powder it's
actually not so bad it reminds me a
little bit of Nutella on button toast I
can dig it
still here man that's a lot of pizza we
at the U.S Domino's have sandwiches
specifically these seven most of them
are just versions of pizza
that are awesome sandwich form first one
would be the buffalo chicken let's get a
look in there the chicken cheese and the
sauce the chicken habanero I like a
habanero thing because it has the sweet
and the spicy pineapple and jalapenos
together in one bite this one we're a
Mediterranean veggie feta cheese and
spinach that's something about a
training area I guess banana peppers
which I don't think exists outside of
the U.S oh the Philly cheese steak
it's it's like double depressing because
this
Philly cheesesteak
Pacific oil being made this is like not
what a Philly cheesesteak is supposed to
look like why do this right over here we
got the chicken bacon ranch bro they
were generous with the ranch look at
that lots of bacon and chicken and the
cheese nice an Italian sandwich
Mamma Mia salami cheese ham and another
salami and of course what is more
Italian than banana peppers and the
chicken parm sandwich chicken parmesan
which is again an incredibly popular
already well established sandwich that
Domino's for some reason felt they
needed to deconstruct and then
reconstruct in a different way
I don't want any of these no sandwiches
here in China but what we do have is
ribeye steak
waiter
[Music]
oh
whoa that's a big piece of steak
hmm
[Music]
let's talk pasta and rice we have both
here are our pasta options all come with
spaghetti or you can pay one extra yen
to upgrade to penne
spag ball looks decent smells good a lot
of Bolognese on the pasta spaghetti
basil I'm pretty sure that's just a
carbonara here we've got a seafood pasta
with scallop and Squid Row here we've
got the rice options chorizo baked rice
you've got some chorizo you've got some
pepperoni truffle flavored baked rice
with chicken and bacon not gonna touch
that don't like my Truffles and just a
nice wholesome Curry Beef rice curry
sauce beef
rice what could go wrong no rice dishes
in the us but we do have our own pastas
four specifically this is the fourth
dominoes food Wars that I've been a part
of I want to again state that I think
the pastas at Domino's are an absolute
Abomination so if you're watching from
outside the U.S and you think this looks
weird you are correct this pasta is so
weird Italian sausage marinara I mean I
can't even break through the skin of
this thing come on man chicken carbonara
oh
it hurts my soul
pasta primavera whatever Primavera means
it ain't this and last chicken alfredo
both countries have wings in China you
can only get your wings in orders of
four unless you go for the wings combo
now here we have four exclusive flavors
Cantonese roast sweet in like a fruity
sort of sweetness and you've got that
barbecue smell
it tastes like Chinatown next we have
the Orleans flavor oh it's very spicy
wow
oh
my gosh
we also have the honey and the barbecue
flavored wings and I believe in the US
you just have them combined as a honey
barbecue but here we get an extra flavor
out of it I'm sure some of you might
have noticed our wings look a little bit
different a wing is made up of three
parts the drum the flat and the tip
usually it's removed because it doesn't
have much meat but here in China we love
fiddly food basically here in China we
love the tip so much that we even have
an entire dish devoted to just the tip
one thing I do love on the menu though
is the Domino's wings in the U.S you can
get Wing orders in 8 16 or 32. we only
have four exclusive flavors starting
down here got the hots then the honey
barbecue
sweet mango habanero and last the garlic
parmesan on the presentation this is is
especially but they are very good I may
still get pizza over wings but the
earwing sides
Domino's wings not bad we also have
roast skewers now these are something
that are popular Street Foods here we've
got some chicken satay skewers we've got
beef skewers these also come in the land
version incredibly delicious and also
yeah
roast sausages I think these are usually
what kids like to eat I don't usually
see adults eating these these would be
sweet sausages but they're very filling
China also has Seafood options namely
our golden shrimp which actually look a
little bit orange Pollock bites and
regular fish bites our other sides
include chicken rolls I believe it's
smoked chicken mayo
an egg and peas as peas peas make it
into every single menu item here at
Domino's many hot dogs wrapped in a very
cute blanket it's almost like it outgrew
its blanket healthy salad star-shaped
hash browns onion rings
and potato wedges and both countries
have garlic bread but ours we do it a
little differently ours is stuffed with
cheese and other stuff for instance this
one right here jalapeno and bacon why
this
over Pizza another one we have here is
the spinach and feta we have twists we
have bites starting over here we've got
the Parmesan bread twists
looks like it's kind of like doing this
like please don't give me diarrhea
garlic bread twists
do you want this taking up space in your
stomach I don't just get more pizza I
mentioned it before we got dips what are
dips what I can tell just big portions
of something to dip these Breads in
first one is oh my good Lord gonna go
ahead and assume this is the five cheese
look at that you look at the oil on this
uh
[Music]
you know what tastes like like pizza
but without the sauce and not to be a
done looks like the cheese one but this
one you guessed it
has
marinara sauce so if you got sick of
having bread with the sauce and cheese
on it you can just get the sauce and
cheese baked and then the bread bakes
separately and just dip them
who wants this instead of pizza I don't
understand but all right we have square
garlic bread and garlic bread I actually
don't know what the difference is beside
the shape but they both come with this
honey Mayo dip I actually thought
this was mustard
I think it's mustard mayo and honey I
think the bread is just an excuse to eat
this dick because this is actually
pretty good we also have soups you can
get a nice bowl of pumpkin cream bacon
classic burst or cream of mushroom soup
desserts unfortunately both China and
the US have lava cakes so it is not
exclusive but we have a couple things
that you can't get in China specifically
these
cinnamon bread twists and the Domino's
marble cookie brownie come on it doesn't
like brownies and you can tell they put
a little cookie dough in there it's a
cookie brownie hybrid and we got this
icing that you would dip in here and I'm
not gonna do it I I've decided I'm
taking a stand against all twists and
bread
not happening sorry here in China our
exclusive dessert options are limited to
Dorian pie I believe this is durian I
had a sniff which durian you can always
tell her something is durian just put
your nose to it pineapple pie
and we have one of two Portuguese egg
Tarts drinks in the US you can get
Sprite Fanta orange Dasani water and Dr
Pepper this is M Blick Leaf flower and
coconut jelly I had to do quite a bit of
research to figure out what an M Blick
is apparently it's some kind of fruit
that actually has a lot to do with
Buddhism but it has great Cooling and
cough relieving properties so this is
perfect for summer when it's too hot
outside
oh
it's kind of nice but it also kind of
tastes like I'm drinking green perfume
if that makes sense it's very very
Floral this is coconut and musk melon
mmm
oh that's tasty it's a little bit too
rich so nay to that and this this is
Karan Bella and Olive that's such a
weird combination right so a carambula
is this thing
it's a star fruit but I've never had it
as a drink and together with Chinese
Olive okay learn something new every day
oh that was a pleasant surprise there
was actually some coconut jelly at the
bottom too that was very inviting we
also just have a regular mango and
passion fruit drink oh and
bottled water
[Music]
Domino's entered China in 1997 but for
about two decades they pretty much just
floundered and nobody took notice of
them it's only really in recent years
that they've become very youthful with
all sorts of wacky flavors as you've
seen and because it's not as common as
McDonald's or KFC in China a Domino's
opening in for example a tier 2 tier 3
city is big news to locals and a lot of
people actually post about it on social
media oh look Domino's has come to our
town it's something to be proud of
diamond was in the US I feel like it's
been Domino's versus Pizza Hut Pizza Hut
versus Domino's since I think the 80s
yes there's other Nationwide pizza
chains Papa John's sucked up a lot of
the attention online for a while there's
a little Caesar there's a bunch of other
ones but it really is Domino's and Pizza
have been neck and neck I mean they're
kind of interchangeable now people watch
are gonna be like no one's better than
the other now I honestly I don't think I
could taste the difference you put them
side by side died but with dominoes as
far as a reputation you always know
you're going to get a good pizza a hot
pizza it's going to be decently priced
which is nice hey in China Domino's main
Rivals are of course Pizza Hut who
dominates the market with a 35 market
share next in line is a local brand
called Champion pizza with 5.6 of the
market share and third comes Domino's at
5.3 of the market share like in the
states Domino's China has a guarantee to
deliver your pizza within 30 minutes
otherwise they will give you all sorts
of discounts this really sets them apart
from other Pizza players here in China
because they use their own proprietary
delivery service whereas most
restaurants in China use a third party
akin to something like Uber Eats it's
also something that's become a bit of a
double-edged sword because people were
actively trying game their 30 minute
delivery window by switching off
Corridor lights removing door numbers
and just generally trying to get their
delivery drivers lost and about half of
all of Domino's salary payments go
towards their delivery drivers which
shows you how big of a delivery Force
they have which is actually kind of
quite nice convenience I mean Domino's
is probably one of the most convenient
uh Peter chains in the United States you
can get you can get a Domino's Pizza you
get in the app it's easy to use the
pizza's at your place in probably 30
minutes depending where you live some
would say too convenient
Domino's in China doesn't disclose their
nutritional information but based on
third-party independent research we
found that a large hand-tossed pepperoni
pizza has
1466.4 calories 64 grams of protein 66.4
grams of fat
155.2 grams of carbs and
3257.6 milligrams of sodium our large
pepperoni is 370 calories per slice or
2960 for the entire pie also
299 of your daily sodium
that's a salty pie Domino's China's most
calorific Pizza is this the large salted
egg yolk flavored chicken pizza with
stuffed sausage crust now one slice is
230 calories and the full Pizza is 1
841 calories our Domino's Pizza with the
most calories is the Kelly chicken bacon
ranch an extra large slice is 560
calories and the full pie 3 360 calories
two ingredients you won't find in
dominoes in China are potassium bromate
and ractopamine both have been banned
for use in China potassium bromate is
used as a dough conditioner as
classified as a category 2B carcinogen
by the international Agency for research
on cancer rectopamine is FDA approved
and it promotes muscle mass development
limits fat deposition and reduces feed
consumption although it is considered
safe for human consumption China
requires all meat sold to be free of the
drug and never fed the product to begin
with there is no direct link stating
rectopamine is specifically used in the
meat at Domino's but on their
stewardship page under Animal Care they
State quote it's important to highlight
that Domino's does not own raised
transport or process the animals use for
our products Domino's purchases pork
beef and poultry ingredients from
suppliers who obtain their products from
Farmers and ranchers who raise and care
for their animals in compliance with low
local state and federal guidelines
industry best practices and the support
of farm and animal veterinarians that is
a very long legalese way of Domino's San
a
we don't Farm to meet we buy them from
other people and they're saying they're
doing it the right way so
we don't know I was traumatized as a kid
because I had a fishbone stuck
horizontally in my throat and I had to
go to the hospital and the doctor
basically reached in and just yanked it
out and for many years I just did not
want to eat fish but in China it's fish
with bones it's all nothing at all so
tough luck you just gotta suck it up